foreign
comes from Mark in Wisconsin in the
current economy what is a reasonable
expectation as far as where home loan
rates will end up by the end of the year
is the three percent rate possible again
or do you think it'll stay where it's at
in looking at my numbers it's depressing
how much I will how much my mortgage
payment would be after putting a lot of
money down so I'm hoping for some light
at the end of the tunnel
you know I mean I I was listening to a
thing off I think it was like YouTube
fine or Yahoo finance or something today
and I mean they're thinking they're
going to raise the federal raise again
and May in uh May and June like so
that's the thing Mark I'm like I don't
know we don't have a crystal ball we
have we have no idea uh is three percent
rate possible by the end of the year no
probably not no not by the end of this
year no
uh however we need to tell you that uh
economists and weather forecasters are
the only people that can be wrong most
of the time and keep their jobs so when
we predict that you know it's just like
who knows but um
realistically it takes it a little while
to settle back down if the markets if
the bond markets settle down and If the
Fed quit screwing with it and so um you
know you've only got about you know
effectively nine months less than that
by the time we have this conversation
and all so I I no not by the end of the
year will we ever see three percent
again oh maybe I don't know
maybe probably the the thing you got to
think about is this
um
in 19
78 I got my real estate license rates
went from nine and three quarters to ten
that September for the first time ever
we saw double-digit interest rates
they didn't settle back down below 10
they went all the way up to 18. in 1982.
under Jimmy Carter
and then they came back down and in the
80s I I don't remember when they came
back down below 10 but it was probably a
decade before they came back around
below 10 and honestly having I was a
young real estate agent at that time and
having lived through it going up up up
up up up up and then it came down from
18 to 14 to 12. even to 11
when I went on the radio in 19 oh I know
wait a minute I know it took more than a
decade because I went on the radio in
1992 and uh they had not gone below 10
and I was telling people you'll never
see it below 10 again and I said that on
the radio and it was completely
obviously I was completely wrong right
and it went below 10 and it stayed in
the in the five six range for a long
long time yeah 2008 crash
drove the rates down below three and
they stayed in the three and Below three
until just the other day yeah until just
about about a year ago so uh the point
being that there's a large percentage
of the history of single-family homes
prospering
in the United States that the rate was
much higher than three percent
six percent nine percent even 11 or 12
percent
and the market move the market continued
to move uh the the only difference was
they didn't have three to compare it to
yeah
I mean you got three to compare it to
and it pisses you should have known yeah
one especially for the millennials that
are the ones that are probably in the
major you know you know yeah housing to
buy yeah I mean all of I mean that's all
we've known yeah 2008. yes so I mean I
think and what I would say too Mark is
when it comes to buying your home we
always say buy home when it's good for
you regardless of what the Market's
doing so regardless of whether the you
know the stock market is like going
crazy or it's down or whatever for the
most part if you have the money and you
have the ability to buy a home
that then then you have the ability to
buy a home and if it goes back down you
can refinance I mean you can always
still get a better interest rates but uh
but it is depressing I get it I mean you
know I get it two points to go with my
little story of perception there okay oh
is the history lesson still going the
history I'm so sorry no no no no the
point for the history lesson and then
I'll land the freaking plane but the uh
just circle you're just circling okay
that's great 10 if you were at 10 18
months ago and it had come down to six
six would not be depressing
it's not the sixth it's depressing it's
the change from three yeah that's what's
depressing and because you saw what you
used to could have had okay and that's
what throws you off so if you bought a
house at six you're not gonna die from
it and go ahead and be pissed off and
get the stupid thing paid off ASAP and
then because my interest rate on my home
is precisely zero because I don't borrow
money
so there's that and you can save up and
pay cash for a house too that's a weird
idea oh that's a really weird idea but
people do it and uh it's not that
unusual it's not as unusual as some of
you think it is so well you know don't
tell me that because I've seen it I've
been doing this for 30 years I see a lot
of people pay cash for a house so just
start going okay I'm gonna say 50 Grand
a year I'm gonna do that for five years
I'm gonna have 250k and I'm gonna buy my
first starter house well you couldn't
get to I know wherever you are I get it
but
the average house price in America's
today is about 300 so you know let's
talk about how you get 300K together or
let's talk about putting a bit a huge
down payment and then getting it paid
off as soon as possible so you don't
have to be pissed off or depressed or
whatever emotion it is associated with
it so yeah perception is part of the
issue the actual math part of the issue
and then it just get you know turn it as
a positive and as a motivator to push
you on out of